رغم عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها في الصين
يبدو ان الدول الغربيه عده لا تزال ترمق
ما يجري هناك بكثير من الربا لم تفلح
اجراءات رفع الاغلاق التي اتخذتها بجين في
طمنه ايطاليا والولايات المتحده واليابان
والهند وكوريا الجنوبيه وتايوان التي قررت
اتخاذ اجراءات احترازيه ضد المسافرين من
الوافدين اليها من الصين تبرر هذه الدول
قراراتها باستمرار تفشي العدوى وتسجيل
وفيات وصلت الى 50 وفاه في اليوم لكن ورغم
القائمه المتزايده للدول المتوجهه من
كورونا اعلن المتحدث باسم الحكومه
البريطانيه انه لا خطط لديه لاعاده فرض
اختبارات فروض 19 على القادمين الى البلاد
في السياق ذاته
وكاله الامراض الاوروبيه فحص المسافرين
القادمين من الصين غير مبرر واعلنت انها
لن تتبع خطاء ايطاليا وفي رد فعل على
مخاوف عدد من الدول قالت الخارجيه الصينيه
انه يجب ان تكون اجراءات الوقايه من
الوباء في مختلف البلدان مناسبه ولا ينبغي
ان تؤثر في التبادلات العاديه للافراد
والتعاون بين الدول هو جدلا يتجدد اذا
بشان وجهها تطبيق السلطات الصينيه لسياسه
الصفر قابض قبل التراجع عنها وبشان
امكانيه ظهور متحور جديد مقلق وخطير اذا
ما تفوق على بقيه المتحولات في قدرته على
اختراق المناعه وقد يعيد البشريه الى
كابوس اليقظه الذي عاشته فتره الجائحه